To begin, let's take a look at
this simple, unstyled webpage.
Looks pretty plain, doesn't it?
Wouldn't it be better if we
could add some style to it?
Maybe we could lay out the content
differently, use a different font, or
emphasize different elements.
CSS can help us do just that.
CSS, or Cascading Style Sheets,
is the markup language that we use
to describe how elements
on websites should look.
CSS is all about style.
Look at YouTube's home page.
With CSS,
it can control things like color,
spacing, fonts, and
layouts for their website.
What makes CSS so
powerful is it gives you,
the web developer, the ability to change
the look of elements on the page.
CSS is also nice because it let's us
separate the description of the content
we want on the page, the HTML,
from the description of how we want the
content to look on the page, the CSS.
Let's look at an example.
This is Yahoo's home page, but what if I
looked at Yahoo's home page without CSS?
What would it look like?
Whoa, looks pretty weird, doesn't it?
The content is still here,
but it looks terrible.
What happened to the navigation
at the top, the menu on the side,
the search bar, and the news stories?
Well, this is the beauty of CSS.
Literally all the code that makes
the page look the way it does
is separate from the text, images,
and content that is on the page.
If I add the CSS back, then we're back
to the same Yahoo home page from before.